I'm pleased to welcome back to the
program David McAfee who's a Religious
Studies graduate a six-time published
author founder of the party of Reason
and progress and the new book is called
no sacred cows which deals with really a
lot of subject matter that we talk about
on the program so so first David you
have been studying and researching
everything from sects to cults to the
belief in the paranormal and religious
beliefs for a very long time so what
what made you want to look more
specifically at what you talked about in
this particular book I started studying
religion specifically when I was 18 I
started majoring in religious studies at
UCSB but it was a few years later that I
started realizing that there was this
gap in information about other
supernatural beliefs and people who
separated them so much and I just saw
any similarities between say
Christianity and it's supernatural
practices like prayer and then other
non-religious supernatural aspects and I
just was so curious to find more
connections between those two and so
that's what I set out to do yeah and
there's a number of studies which point
out I believe accurately that there is a
decrease in sort of devout religious
belief and also just more casual
association with organized religion but
at the same time you talk in the book
about how we're not seeing the same an
equivalent I guess we would say decrease
in belief in supernatural claims that
are outside of religious belief so first
how do we measure that and then we can
maybe get into some of the more common
beliefs yeah and that's exactly accurate
every study that I've seen every
reputable study that I've seen has shown
a rise in people who don't identify with
any particular religious tradition they
call it the rise of the nuns the the
unaffiliated people and so a lot of
people assume that that means that we
are seeing a lot more critical thinking
and people are thinking through these
things and deciding not to adhere to
these traditions but when you look at
other polls about belief in ghosts and
psychics and and
supernatural beliefs that you would
think would be on the same tier they
tend to be rising at a pretty rapid rate
and so that's why I wrote this book was
because I thought that that needed the
attention because people seem to be
under the impression that they're always
correlated and it's really not true what
would be a top-line general explanation
because on the one hand we like to think
that the reason for the decline in
religiosity is as science develops and
as sort of knowledge of empiricism
spreads through the world
it maybe eliminates the need or place
for organized or devout religious
beliefs but if that were the sole reason
or primary reason you'd imagine you'd
have fewer people believing in psychics
and ancient aliens as well exactly I
think the problem is that people aren't
necessarily thinking more critically
about all their beliefs they might be
pushing a religion away for any number
of reasons for one it's it's more
ancient than a lot of these beliefs it
ties into a specific dogma so with
ghosts and and other supernatural
beliefs there's not really this book
this bounds you to believe in it and it
might be a push away from that away from
the rigidity of religion and toward the
fluidity of New Age beliefs and what are
the most common I mean you talked about
psychics and you alluded to some others
but when we're talking about
supernatural beliefs what's that what's
included there and what are the most
common I would say angels and demons
tend to be the most common when I looked
at polls it seemed like even more people
believed in angels in the United States
than identified with Christianity from
which you would think that they would be
getting the angel concept but there's an
entire separate belief system there from
people who believe in angels but don't
believe in any religion they believe in
guardian angels or just some big concept
that they grew up with but it's true
with all of these different supernatural
beliefs we can name thousands of them
and and I do in the book but I think the
problem is that people are just wanting
to believe in something bigger and
they're moving away from religion they
need something else too
move toward that's not always something
supernatural but in many cases it is in
other cases it's conspiracy theories
which also factor in that same idea that
there's something greater controlling
everything well that was what I was next
going to sort of mention which is the
overlap in the sort of processes that
take place in someone's mind that get
them to the conclusion of some
supernatural belief or concluding that a
conspiracy theory is actually the
explanation for some phenomena in our
world rather than whatever the so-called
official story is do you believe that it
is the same sort of process that gets
people to those end conclusions
mm-hm I much argue that in the book that
that the same failing the same failures
of critical thinking lead to all of
these different false beliefs whether
it's religion or even these Colts or
conspiracy theories or other
supernatural beliefs it's because
somebody didn't take the time to think
okay let's look at what has been
scientifically proven and then we
compare that to what what I want to
believe you got to separate your desires
you have to separate what your friends
and family have told you to believe
these are all influences that aren't
necessarily going to get you to the
right place but people trust their
family they trust their friends and so
if they're if they say that they saw a
ghost then you had a feeling ones that
you might have seen a ghost that belief
becomes solidified and there's not
really much that can change it it's
similar to religion in that instance
talk a little bit about both for this
book but also in your past you've done
some of this some of what I guess I'd
call them undercover incidents or
undercover attempts to learn more about
some of these phenomena definitely this
book was kind of my biggest step in that
direction because it contains I think at
least 10 different interviews with
believers with psychics with members of
the Westboro Baptist Church with the
great-grandson of l ron Hubbard and and
not all of these interviews not in all
of them do I identify myself as a
skeptic I just basically asking
questions to these peoples
and in this book I decided to take it
one step further and I actually trained
myself to become a psychic to become a
seer a cold reader and I started
performing on Venice Beach and I went
undercover in that way and it really
really opened my eyes to how these
beliefs are formed and solidified
because there were people who were so
convinced by my presentation which was
completely not magic of course that they
that they wouldn't believe me when I
revealed at the end that I was a skeptic
and that this was a thought experiment
they refused to believe me they said
that I was just trying to cover myself
so that the government wouldn't come get
me I I had people trying to give me so
much money and I was like no these are
completely free readings I didn't take a
dollar but the this one woman in
particular just wanted to give me money
and I was like this must be such an easy
job for the people who really do it and
want to take money so I mean I think
that how long it takes one to learn the
skill of cold reading which is sort of
the underlying skill in what is
colloquially described as being a
psychic I think that depending on one's
emotional intelligence so to speak it
could take you more or less time to
learn those skills and to play off of
the reactions of the person you're
reading but can you tell us a little bit
about how long your training was and
what it consisted of yes so I've always
really been good at reading people at
reading their expressions on their face
and and guessing what they're thinking
based on that and I never really took it
the next step obviously to to pretend to
be psychic so this was really really
easy for me I would say I read books for
about two months before I actually did
my first live show and and I would just
practice even online I would go on
online chats and even just seeing
somebody's picture and talking to them
online I was able to guess things like
their name by just putting a letter on
the keyboard and then they'll say oh
that's that letters in my name and then
I can kind of figure it out from there
and I've also used warm reading hot
reading where you can research the
person who's in front of you before they
get there or while they're there
there are a lot of different tricks that
I used I would say about two three
months of total preparation and I didn't
have any dissatisfied customers um what
are some of the key books in your
research that you read Oh
psychic sciences is a really good one
that's from the point from the point of
view of believers of course but then I
also read a lot of books by James Randi
he has really done so much work on that
topic that there wasn't there isn't
anybody who's done more than him so I
read all of his books on the topic yeah
and it helped me out so much because I
was able to see how he exposed other
psychics and so I was able to learn from
those mistakes and when people tried to
expose me which did happen quite a few
times I was able to anticipate that and
then make it even more impressive for
them really
so you said earlier that similarly to
religious beliefs that their it is
difficult to get people to critically
re-examine how they came to these sort
of supernatural beliefs can you give us
some of the better ways to try to get
people to re-examine those beliefs and
I'm sort of brought to the basic sort of
epistemology Socratic method of
questioning that we've heard from people
like Peter Bergen and others right
exploring how someone came to a
conclusion and what it might take to
change their mind are sort of the some
of the few inroads that we might be able
to make that's exactly right I talk a
lot in the book about the Socratic
method and how questions help people
understand these concepts more than
statements so if I were to tell you this
is how a psychic works people are less
likely to believe believe me than if I
said well how do you think they came to
this conclusion why would this psychic
say I'm feeling a letter and and and
then named the letter why would a ghost
or a spirit speak to them in letters and
fragments instead of if they're really
they're actually speaking to them and
and why is everything so vague and and
so when I asked those type of types of
questions and it's not like anybody is
like Oh psychics are fake and all this
stuff is fake and walked away but it
does plant that seed of doubt and and
that's really what it's all about I also
talked about how
do all that while being extremely nice
it never helps or it rarely helps to be
confrontational and so I'm very polite
in all my discussions and I really try
to focus on the actual issues to try to
criticize with kindness as Daniel
Dennett has said and and it seems to
work very well that way the book is
fascinating we've been speaking with the
author of the new book no sacred cows
David McAfee he's a religious Studies
graduate six-time published author and
also the founder of the party of Reason
and progress David great job with the
book and thanks so much for talking to
us about it
thank you very much for having me again
I appreciate it